the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire update video well
my friends it looks like we now have
confirmation from our beloved mother of
dragons according to emilia clarke she
says kit harrington is in fact working
on a jon snow sequel series with hbo
now for those of you who haven't heard
about this yet james hibbard who writes
for the hollywood reporter released an
article stating mr harrington was in the
works on a jon snow sequel series at hbo
this new jon snow series would show us
what is happening with jon snow after
the events of game of thrones when we
saw him ghost and the small group of
wildlings head north of the wall at the
end of season 8. hbo still hasn't
confirmed this themselves however amelia
has now given us a confirmation because
she said kit harrington has told her
about this himself let me show you
exactly what was said during emilia's
new interview in the new article written
by the bbc it says amelia will be
watching the new game of thrones
successor show house of the dragon i'm
going to watch this as a fresh viewer
because it's set a bajillion years
before our show so it will feel
different and in response to a story in
the hollywood reporter that kid
harrington will renew his role as jon
snow in a game of thrones sequel amelia
says he has told me about it and i know
it exists it's happening it's been
created by kid as far as i can
understand so he's in it from the ground
up so what you will be watching
hopefully if it happens is certified by
kid harrington himself well there you
have it ladies and gentlemen maybe you
don't believe james hibbard when he says
this will happen but i find it hard not
to believe amelia clarke because as we
all know she knows kid harrington very
well i just don't see her saying
something like this unless it were real
she sounds very confident in the fact
that not only is it happening but kit
harrington is helping create it from the
ground up
now like i already said before just
because he might be working on this show
with hbo doesn't mean it will ever see
the light of day this certainly would
not be the first time hbo developed the
game of thrones successor show that
never actually released now this doesn't
mean kid harrington will be writing or
even directing anything either that's
not to say he can't or won't but saying
he is working on the show from the
ground up most likely means he is
helping develop it maybe he's giving
them some ideas for its direction
game of thrones writers dan and dave
will not be working on the show either i
feel like i need to say that because for
some reason fans always ask if they are
involved with the game of thrones
successor shows well i'm here to say
they are not dan and dave no longer work
for hbo they haven't worked there for
years with that being said i did have a
feeling something like this would
eventually happen i have been saying it
for months now in several of my videos i
have said i would bet a number of game
of thrones actors would be willing to
come back for another show once they had
several years to see what their other
options are outside of game of thrones
now that game of thrones has been off
the air for several years some of them
most likely miss working on one of the
biggest shows in the history of
television some of them most likely miss
being seen as one of the most
recognizable characters on any format
when game of thrones ended a lot of them
were burned out from the decade-long
grind but now they've had three years
off
now they have seen what other roles they
are being offered and unfortunately for
some of them they will never work on
something this big ever again
not all of them of course but you know
it will be accurate for most this show
will focus on jon snow because he is
obviously the most recognizable
character who is still alive in this
story however that doesn't mean other
characters from game of thrones can't
show back up either i know some of you
already think this show will only be
about jon snow but if this does actually
happen and fans do show up for it i
guarantee hbo will do everything they
can to get some of the other actors back
you have to remember hbo did not want
game of thrones to end they offered dan
and dave a lot more money to keep things
going but they wanted it to be over so
they could work on other things well hbo
didn't they want to keep this gravy
train moving right along which is why
they keep developing all these other
shows in the song of ice and fire
universe we all know they have to go up
against netflix amazon disney and many
others believe me when i say this hbo
wants game of thrones back on our
screens as bad as season 8 was it was
their most successful season ever the
ratings were still through the roof no
matter how bad the fans reacted to it
they wanted a game of thrones season 9
and beyond whether anyone else wants to
admit that or not that is what they
wanted and i believe it's what they
still want because that is what will be
the most successful out of any of the
other show ideas they have in mind i
mean sure game of thrones is over they
no longer have george rr martin's novels
to follow and sure a lot of the actors
will never want to come back but do you
actually think that means hbo will stop
if they think they can make something
work as in make something that will make
them money
i don't think so they already unloaded
30 million dollars into a long night
show that was never released then they
moved right onto another show and gave
it a full series order without even
seeing a single second of the footage
you should see that as a hint
they want game of thrones in some shape
or form back on the air it is a billion
dollar franchise and they still have
millions of fans who want to see it
whether you me or other hardcore fans
think it's a good idea or not they don't
want a jon snow movie they want a jon
snow series that will hopefully open up
the door for some of the other
characters from the original series to
come back to bring in even more of the
fans
now i will admit i very well could be
wrong about all of this however this is
what i believe
as some of you may remember i've been
saying this even before maisie williams
flirted with the idea of making another
show
as we get further and further away from
the ending of game of thrones and more
and more the actors realize they will
never work on something like this again
they will wish they were back on that
set still making the biggest and most
successful show ever made
they might have been burned out after a
decade of making this show i don't doubt
that but after several years of falling
off the radar who wouldn't want to come
back and instantly step into a
recognizable role that also happens to
come with massive amounts of money at
least for a handful of them
again maybe i am wrong maybe none of
this will actually ever happen
i guess we will just have to wait and
see
now during emilia's new interview she
also said she thinks she is done with
game of thrones meaning she doesn't
think she will ever sign on for another
show
as much as i know some of you want to
see that maybe it is for the best
because it would obviously be really
difficult for them to do anything with
their story even if they did resurrect
her
as i have stated before i would be open
to daenerys coming back depending on how
they did it and what they did with their
character afterwards i don't even really
want to get into all that until we know
more about this jon snow sequel series
this would obviously have to move
forward first before we could even
really consider something like that
i will never say never though because i
do think hbo would consider it
themselves if they had a great idea for
it as of right now though let's just see
what else happens with the jon snow show
let's see if any more interesting
information is announced in the
following days or weeks as we lead up to
house of the dragon
make sure you do subscribe so you can
stay up to date on any and all news and
updates regarding game of thrones their
successor shows and the ones of winter
as always i want to thank all of you for
watching the video
i hope all of you have a great day i
will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
you